this way you make the perfect summary
that will help you get better grades anyway
I have 1 comprehensive step-by-step plan for you
this is by the way
also 1 very nice step-by-step plan
when you have final exams soon
first do not start with the summary itself
but with 1 overview of your exam material
I have kept this
next to the
assignments that I had to practice from my exam
and HAVE some there
terms written down
which I had not quite mastered
and I wrote 1 kind of cheat sheet for myself
so actually 1 cheat sheet that I
would like to stick to the test afterwards
it must be clear and legible
so I used colors and enough white lines
really don't take too long
because your summary must work for you
you don't have to work for your summary
then use your summary
as a cheat sheet when practicing assignment or
exams and it should be all right
for more tips like this in this book
really 1 whole chapter about summarizing
and for now I wish you the best of luck